في اسرائيل لا اكتملت عوده رئيس الوزراء
المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو الى سده الحكم من
خلاله عرض حكومه الجديده حكومه سرقت
الانظره حتى قبل تعيينها فالعديد من
المصادر تصف وبالحكومه الاكثر تشددا في
تاريخ اسرائيل ماذا تحمل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده للفلسطينيين سؤال لا
تبعث الاجابه عليه بالتفاؤل الكبير ملف
شائك سيكون مصدر توتر جديد بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين وهم ملف توسيع
المستوطنات نتنياهو وضع من بين اولوياته
توسيع المستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه بل
ايضا الشرعيه على عشرات البؤر الاستيطانيه
كما ان نتوسع يشمل الجليل والنقب
والمرتفعات الجولان والضفه الغربيه
توسيع المستوطنات لا يثيره حفيظه
الفلسطينيين فحسب المعظم المجتمع الدولي
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده وهو ما جاء
على لسان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكل الذي وعد بمواصله معارضه الاستيطان
الاسرائيلي او ضم الاراضي في الدقه
الغربيه السلطه الفلسطينيه من جهتها ردت
على خطه نتنياهو في توسيع المستوطنات حيث
ادانا نبيل ابو ردينه المتحدث باسم الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس ادام الخطوط العريضه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده معتبرا ذلك
تصعيدا خطيرا ستكون له تداعيات على
المنطقه
بتخيوط
[موسيقى]